good evening I'm Stuart brand from long
now all that growth is self-organized
but Kevin calls hivemind piece of advice
on these question cards we've discovered
that there's a clear pattern over cast
questions actually make it to the
speakers through Kevin and then through
me it's the ones that are extremely
legible in short there's a website now
you can go to and you can see a live
image is from the Space Science
satellite looking out and down and
mostly and you go to it and it's not the
black because it's night or it's great
because they're changing cameras or it's
blue because it's looking down at the
ocean most of the time and you're
looking at is there something wrong here
and that cloud goes by it's moving very
quickly and they think well that's
really boring
there's so much of it you realize
actually from a space that's earth is
it's not earth it's ocean and then
you're down on the surface of the ocean
and it's incredibly turbulent and you're
in danger of drowning and there's things
that might eat you and it's all very
fast-moving but if you're in boat and
you get this realization that comes
after a while it's all connected and you
can go anywhere and the things that live
in there can go anywhere and do so to
start us on that journey
here's turning keys
[Applause]
well hi everybody I'm really happy to be
here tonight the ocean is arguably the
single most complex largest feature on
our planet it's the one feature that
sets us apart from every other planet in
the known universe and well it's often
said that we live in on in a small world
our ocean is immense like Stuart were
saying and we've seen less than 5% of it
with our own eyes volumetrically 99
percent of Earth's habitable living
space lies under sea which means that we
landlubbers live on a mere 1 percent of
the available living space on the planet
and despite the fact that we're in this
you know sequestered 1% occupation we
are having a huge effect on the rest of
the 99 so what to do about that well I
figured the best thing is to dive in and
get wet so in the spirit of long-term
thinking I thought it would be fun for
us to take a long ocean journey together
driven by the motion of the ocean itself
and for this adventure we will be riding
on the great ocean conveyor belt a round
trip will take us between a thousand to
1,500 years to complete but will will
move along at a steady clip and will
finish before dawn actually in about 25
minutes so ok so should we get started
let's dive in alright so let's dive into
the Gulf Stream this famous current was
created when the Isthmus of Panama rose
up some 4 and a half million years ago
to join North and South America
separating the Pacific in the atlantic
ocean basins and that little act changed
everything it created the ocean
circulation patterns we have today
as we glide know north we will be
passing through an unfathomable amount
of genetic microbial diversity just last
month
MIT researchers found that the most
abundant photosynthetic organism on the
planet prochlorococcus a cyanobacteria
best known for creating a lot of the
oxygen that we breathe
this little cyanobacteria has these
little vesicles on it and within those
vesicles are lots of unique flexible
sets of DNA rapid that's a capable of
rapid of rapidly evolving so when you
think of prochlorococcus which is a
billion billion billion cells and you
add these little vesicles on each cell
to it the amount of genetic diversity
within our ocean is and that's just one
species is almost inconceivable so
there's a lot of genetic power in the
saline soup we're swimming through so
speaking of swimming why don't we take a
little dip into the Sargasso Sea while
we're here and this is a floating golden
rainforest home to mysterious eels and
fish with fingers this place is part of
what's known as the high seas ocean
regions outside any country's economic
jurisdiction the no man's land protected
by no one yet they comprise about 58 on
the 60 percent of the ocean the Sargasso
Sea is special though because just in
March five countries got together to
sign the Hamilton pact protect pledging
to protect the the Sargasso Sea so
hopefully soon it will join a small but
promising handful of high seas protected
areas and more will follow high seas are
a high priority right now in ocean
conservation the Sargasso is also one of
sylvius hope spots and these are places
around the globe where we can still see
ocean the oceans vibrancy at work and
you'll be hearing more of those when
Sylvia takes the stage so stay tuned on
the hope spots
now speaking of hope spot
and marine protected areas the um the
the the marine protected area atlas MPA
Atlas says we have about 8,000 marine
protected areas which is about less
still less than 3% of the world's ocean
protected now it's good news that we
have so many it's that's so many more
than in the last ten years and the rate
of putting in marine protected areas has
really increased but we still have a
long way to go before we have 20% of the
ocean protected and the aim is to get
that protected by 2020 so I'm the that's
the goal set by many scientists so that
we can protect enough ocean before
causing more irrevocable damage so
continuing north let's let's continue
our journey and as we move north we will
pass by George its banks off of off of
Cape Cod home to one of the most famous
fisheries 500 year old fishery the
Atlantic cod fishery which crashed
famously in the 90s due to over
exploitation but there is some good news
here today many of the US fisheries are
actually starting to rebound like we
have Alaskan Pollock Mid Atlantic
bluefish haddock black sea bass and most
recently the little menhaden are getting
protected as well the forage fish so for
us Fisheries we're starting to recovery
thanks in large part to the Magnuson
Stephenson Act and strict regulations
but unfortunately this is not the case
for the rest of the world where globally
global fisheries two-thirds of them are
still over exploited the important thing
to remember here is that we Americans
import up to 90 percent of our seafood
so and that supports a 10 billion dollar
industry and about a third of our wild
import are are illegally caught so it
doesn't matter how you like yourseif
food cooked by the time it reaches your
plate a third of its gonna already
arrive poached
sorry I just had to put that in so you
know our seafood consumption is second
only to China and so the choices we make
at the market and at the at the
restaurants that's having a huge impact
on supporting or not supporting globally
destructive fisheries the take-home
message is eat more vegetables just like
your mom told you to and if you do buy
or order fish buy fish that are low on
the food chain and that are caught by us
well-managed fisheries and also support
policies that enforce mandatory seafood
tracking so while we're up north here
let's continue our journey and we will
pay a visit over to Scotland a place
sometimes referred to as the Saudi
Arabia of renewable resources due to its
wind and and
tidal currents here in the Pentland
Firth right there at the top of of
Scotland we see we find some of the
fastest moving tidal currents in the
world about 30 kilometres an hour and
it's also the site of the proposed site
of Europe's largest tidal turbine array
which is predicted to extract about
sixteen thousand gigawatt hours a year
for Scotland now - as a point of
reference Diablo Canyon just it's south
of here power plant delivers about
18,000 gigawatt hours of electricity
annually which is about seven percent of
California's energy needs
so Scotland's tidal energy extraction if
this goes in and does what it's
predicted to do is looking pretty pretty
respectable globally ocean energy is
still a bit player but in in our fossil
fuel economy but it can in some regions
really make a significant impact like
Scotland which is trying to decarbonize
its economy by 2030 and that's some
pretty good long-term thinking
I'd say so as we've traveled north to
Scotland it's gotten chillier and our
warm salty tropical waters have cooled
and become more dense the winds have
stolen the fresh water from them and
they become even saltier and they've
started to sink and this process is
called deep water formation it also
happens down in Antarctica and it's the
driving force of our global ocean
conveyor belt also known as thermohaline
circulation thermo Heat Helin salt so so
that's that's our our mechanism and so
while we're up here I figured we'd take
a fun detour to see the largest wat the
tallest waterfall in the world the
Denmark Strait cataract located between
Iceland and Greenland and that is not it
you can't see the world's tallest
waterfall because it's underwater but if
you could it would be three times taller
than Angel Falls which is what that is
and it'd be 2,000 times Niagara at peak
flow so next time you're up there you
could try to find that one it's kind of
a fun detour okay so back onto our
journey alright so um acing along we
will continue down staying deep and race
along the ragged edge of the world's
longest mountain range 10,000 kilometers
long the mid-atlantic ridge this is
where seafloor crust is conjured from
the bowels of the earth and it's also
where the theory of continental drift
was proven when when the mid-atlantic
ridge was discovered it's also what
broke up Pangaea some 200 million years
ago and you know give us another 250
million years and we may have another
supercontinent but for now if you've got
old world new world differences well you
can just blame it on a mid-atlantic
ridge so let's see we'll just come
continue on and stay deep the currents
get a little complicated here but well
tinu our journey will stay deep in this
current and will follow our follow it
down up under africa this little current
is our return current that'll take us
home later on but we'll take this and
we'll sidle up next to Madagascar you
know they just found a new continent
underwater next to Madagascar called
Marusya later on that I'll talk to you
about that later and then we'll go past
Bangladesh where we'll have 18 million
people displaced in the next 40 years
due to rising sea levels and we'll stop
right about here okay then nice little
circle around the Indian Ocean and we're
gonna stop here at the search site of
air Malaysia flight 370 a lengthy
unrequited search which underscores just
how much of the ocean still remains
difficult to access an image even with
such amazing technologies a synthetic
aperture sonar and synthetic aperture
radar so this tragedy of air Malaysia
also underscores the enormous amount of
trash in our ocean that machs up any
search rest search and rescue operations
the Indian Ocean like every other ocean
basin has a circular gyre that swirls
around thousands hundreds of tons of
trash human-made trash and recent
tallies estimate about five point two
five trillion particles of plastic
weighing half a million tons are in our
ocean so this plastic doesn't biodegrade
and last for hundreds of years but it's
not just the plastic the plastic
actually concentrates pollutants like PB
DDT's and PCBs so they're actually like
these little poison pills so that's
that's sort of a rather unsavory
long-term legacy the solution reduce
reuse redesign plastics and our and our
trash streams so we don't add more to
the mix
and it's such great news to hear that
San Francisco is making steady headway
on this banning plastic bags and
single-use water bottles by October go
San Francisco really setting a great
example for the rest of the world to
follow definitely and you could check
out the plastic pollution coalition for
more solutions there okay so continuing
our journey along we will we will stay
on our deep water current here and join
the Antarctic circumpolar current the
mother of all currents here the largest
one that circles all the way around here
this is the one that allows for exchange
between the indian atlantic and pacific
ocean basins it's really the the big
current and it's circular flow there you
can see is what helps keep warm waters
away from antarctica and keep that
continent the white continent that task
however is getting a quite a bit tougher
these days two independent studies
confirmed last week that the collapse of
the West Antarctic Ice Sheet is well
underway and has likely gone past the
point of no return and once this glacier
right here the thwaite glacier finishes
melting as pictured here it will raise
sea levels two feet in the next 200
years and it's predicted to act as a
rather a lynchpin for the rest of this
entire West Antarctic Ice Sheet and when
that melts that will raise sea level
another 10 to 13 feet 3 to 4 meters
globally so this is the big elephant in
the room isn't it or perhaps elephant
seal as the case may be
sea level rise is inevitable in our
future in places like Panama Miami
Boston New York Maldives Cara Bosch
Bangladesh all these places are going to
be seeing large inevitable changes that
said it's not all bad down here down in
Antarctica just a few weeks ago the
International
feeling Commission closed down Japan's
scientific whaling which is great so
upwards of 400 minke whales will be
spared so that's great now how the
whales and marine life will fare down
here in the face of these large
freshwater influxes and warming well
Adelie penguins are already suffering
and it's a big area hot area of research
okay now recall this circumpolar current
it goes all the way around Antarctica
well these waters can stay deep or they
can join surface waters and return to
the Gulf Stream so if we run the
animation backwards we can pick up that
return trip here right here this current
here and so remember we're running the
animation backwards so the current looks
like it's going the wrong direction but
it's actually taking us this way and
we'll pass Galapagos and across the
Pacific and we will head into the most
beautiful part of the Pacific right here
hmm the epicenter of marine diversity
the Coral Triangle now this is this is
an amazing amazing place you find more
than 500 species of coral 3,000 species
of fish six of the world's seven turtle
species
dugong cetaceans the works and it's a
global priority for ocean conservation
just north of the triangle we find
Micronesia and Palau whose inspiring
President Tommy remengesau is banning
all commercial fishing in his waters an
area roughly the size of France for him
ecotourism which brings in about 85
million dollars a year compared to
fisheries mostly from Japan and Taiwan
which brings in about five million
dollars a year it's kind of a no-brainer
ecotourism wins out in this case a live
shark and tuna is worth thousands more
than a dead one so further below this
another Hope story
we've got new caledonia which Justin
stated the Natural Park of the Coral Sea
1.3 million square kilometers 500,000
square miles an area about the size of
Alaska and according to Conservation
International the largest protected area
on land or sea so that's big that just
happened
big news so the question now becomes how
do you enforce these vast areas to make
them instead of just being paper parks
honest to goodness real protected areas
and there's some really promising tech
solutions in that realm first we've got
some low-cost planetary satellite
observing systems like planet labs dove
systems these are these little guys can
survey the entire planet every day and
make those data available to the world
for free gotta love that and the skybox
is another company imaging the planet
regularly both companies are
california-based got some great
innovation here this kind of technology
can keep a near real-time eye on coastal
changes and potentially illegal fishing
operations secondly there are low cost
surface surveillance vehicles like
liquid robotics wave gliders powered by
the motion of the ocean and the sail
drone powered by the wind
both of these made here in the Bay Area
again I'm seeing a trend here having to
do with the Bay Area so these vehicles
can listen and scan for illegal fishing
boats and operations that can carry lots
of sensors as can aerial drones so
recently an Australian company Aero
Sande tested their aerial drones in
Palau and are making steady headway to
help out mpa enforcement over there and
here in the Bay Area shall be a National
Geographic emerging Explorer is making
ocean drones for conservation as well in
his project called soar
Oshin so these I find are great reasons
for hope promising automated solutions
that could be applied across the world
to empower local groups for to protect
their own MPAs so now if we follow the
current if we follow our current back on
our journey we could take this this
current and ride that all the way back
to the Gulf Stream but I think and and
and end up where we started but instead
I think there's one section of the belt
we've yet to explore actually there are
lots but we can only do so much and and
tonight I'd like to end by exploring our
own waters off of California here and
we'll get there by going back to this
little spot here and right here taking
this deep deep water current right there
you can see faintly and then well well
we'll take that up into the Pacific here
and explore there now this deep water
current holds the oldest ocean water the
water that's been far from the far from
the surface the longest it's also some
of the most acidic water and when these
old cold acidic waters up well next to
our shores they can have a corrosive
impact on a lot of the creatures here
like for instance these little snails
called pteropods
or sea butterflies that can comprise a
large part of the diet of pink salmon
walleye pollock and tuna recently Oregon
State researchers did surveys and they
found that 53 percent of the little
pteropods they sampled they're supposed
to have these clear shells their shells
were all pitted and pockmarked and
starting to dissolve 53% of them and
that's expected to go up rapidly in the
net in the coming years boys are being
affected as well Taylor shellfish farm
in in Sheldon Washington the the
nation's largest supplier of shellfish
has had to move it's it's some oyster
Lari to Hawaii to less acidic waters
so that their larvae have a better
chance of survival and this just isn't
happening in the Pacific this is
globally we have changed the chemistry
of the ocean lowering the pH from 8.2 5
to 8.1 4 in less than about in about 250
years that's a 30% change and it's this
is the key it's a hundred times faster
than any pH changes that have happened
in the ocean in the last 20 million
years that is a rate that's very
difficult for the animal world and the
life to keep pace with so for those
unfamiliar with the mechanism the ocean
observed absorbs about a third of our
carbon emissions and when carbon dioxide
meets seawater one of products it makes
is carbonic acid which lowers ocean pH
the lower the pH the more acidic with
severe consequences for animals relying
on calcium carbonate like oysters
pteropods corals coral reefs deeper
colder waters can hold more gas and more
co2 respiratory waste from ocean life as
well so dealing and adapting to ocean
acidification it's going to be one of
our biggest long-term challenges because
those deep waters rise as we can see in
this conveyor belt and we just don't
know how these rapid changes are going
to play out on the megafauna of the
world ocean many of whom live here off
of California in an area that's been
called the blue Serengeti this these are
the tracks of dozens of species from
from blue whales to white sharks to
ocean sunfish
my particular favorite and I love this
image because it represents just the
hundreds of scientists and thousands of
satellite tags that we now have been
able to reveal the the movements of
these animals like never before
and you know it just confirms what we
already knew that the left coast is the
hottest hippest place to hang out in the
world ocean we knew that didn't we yeah
well Nino said I'd tell
does that but so if researchers are
working on wiring the ocean even further
with mobile listening stations able to
record real-time data and relay it to
our smart phones so that we can know the
whereabouts of whales and white sharks
we can avoid ship strikes and other
unwanted encounters that way and so our
traditional what's been viewed as
paparazzi oceanography where we we cover
a WoW event here and a WoW event there
that's slowly starting to change well
actually more and more rapidly with
ocean animals as our research assistants
and the creation of things like cabled
observatories like this one down in
Monterey Bay run by the Monterey Bay
Aquarium Research Institute we can have
24/7 presence in the ocean and that's
really the key to understanding it
having coordinated consistent coverage
it takes time infrastructure money a lot
of funding doesn't like to do these long
term projects a lot of funding
mechanisms but it's really it's really
the key to figuring out our long term
future in the ocean and there's
something else that really gives me a
great shot of adrenaline when I think
about our deep future in the ocean it's
the bounty of ways every person on this
planet can explore the ocean study the
ocean and conserve its resources
projects like sea hack you guys know
about sea hack this is a portal of
citizen science projects that everyone
can play a part from identifying
plankton to deciphering whale songs to
checking on the health of of coral reefs
it's so many great meaningful ways to do
to do science the maker movement that's
rocket launching our ocean curiosity
take for example David Lankes great
ocean ROV project open open ROV project
David is in the audience so you must
find him and his team he's here today
another great project from the Bay Area
I might add
providing kits
kids and adults to build their own
underwater vehicles now in 50 countries
so that it's just a great project there
and their online courses like from
Coursera and future learn that are
granting us free access to some of the
great ocean professors out there news
aggregating groups like upwells tide
report that make it easy to keep your
finger on the pulse of what's happening
in the ocean so you can stay up to date
we have all these pieces of the puzzle
we just need to start fitting them
together so I'll leave you with these
final thoughts earth alone holds the
only known accessible liquid ocean in
the universe
oh oh I forgot that one last thing
Google ocean which help you Sylvia help
start Google ocean and Caitlin sea view
has some are taking essentially making
underwater Street view so you can put
the ocean onto your desktop and explore
it in panoramic detail and they were
just in Raja Ampat last month in March
so they're another one to to watch for
being able to explore the ocean from
your desktop is fabulous so so getting
back you know earth alone holds the only
known accessible liquid ocean in the
universe Mars appears to have had an
ocean but lost it presumably due to
solar winds other forces
Jupiter's Europa Saturn's Enceladus they
may have liquid oceans but they're
buried miles under a thick icy shell it
appears earth alone has retained its
watery blue ocean in the face of solar
winds and increasing solar luminosity
why
in large part thanks to the relentless
respiratory processes of Earth's
bountiful life a life the life that
emerged evolved and diversified in our
ocean and then crawled out on the land
Earth's life has helped retain our
liquid ocean which in turn has around
has allowed life on Earth to flourish as
a member of this grand scheme on what
side of human history do we want to
place our smart selves when life
promotes life wondrous things emerge
like psychedelic cuttlefish an amazing
manta rays that seem to somersault with
joy as they swim filtering the water
certain searching for food and
intelligent entities emerge like
graceful cetaceans and conscious humans
wondrous things I think are still to
come on this watery planet and I dearly
dearly want our species to bear witness
to a bountiful future not just for the
next hundred years but at least for the
next 10,000 we've got all the tools as
never before to harness our problems
apes are problem solving 7 billion
brains now it's just time to get to work
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well tyranny thank you you have set the
stage taking all my best lines but
really we're talking about the ocean
here it's just as you point out it's
most of the living world both in terms
of abundance and in terms of diversity
we're focusing here on the long now
think about how long it has taken to get
to where we are now at least we have
some idea that earth is four-and-a-half
billion years in the making and it's
only fairly recently in that long
stretch of time that Earth has been
hospitable for the likes of us
even half a billion years ago would have
been an unfriendly place for big mammals
big oxygen hungry creatures such as we
there's plenty of life on Earth half a
billion years ago when I dive into the
ocean as tyranny has just taken all of
us diving into the ocean many of the
creatures that we encounter along the
way we may even be pretty much the way
they were then a lot of new things
arrived like fish and birds trees many
of the things that are here now that
have taken a long time for Earth to
acquire but here's the shocking thing
it's
a very short period of time for
humankind to alter the nature of nature
to change the basics of what brought us
here in the first place attorney
mentioned changing the chemistry of the
ocean well if I were some alien out
there charged with trying to undo the
four and a half billion years of
whatever it has taken to get us to this
amazing place that we we think of as
ours
think of the way humans think of
themselves it wasn't long ago that
Galileo was was given a really hard time
because he challenged the idea that
earth was not the center of the universe
but we still kind of think of ourselves
humans as being the center of the
universe it's just a fact we think we're
the big boss of the world maybe of the
universe at least that's the way it
appears when you consider the way we
behave burning through the assets that
have taken all preceding time Garden of
Eden if you will but it's really a blue
ocean that drives the way the world
functions delivers most of the oxygen in
the atmosphere through biological
processes but even that process
photosynthesis wasn't here when first
life appeared it's taken a long time to
get to the now that we share it's only
taken a few hundred years mainly the
last 200 but at an accelerating pace so
I think it's safe to say that in the
last half-century
at the same time that we've had this
explosion
of new knowledge new information
learning more perhaps than during all
preceding history about big questions
who are we where do we come from
and maybe most importantly where are we
going we have the capacity now to not
only ask those questions I suppose
humans and maybe even elephants and
whales and dolphins and some pretty
smart fish that I know maybe they want
to know as a child might out where did I
come from
you keep asking that question I do owe
my life where have we come from maybe
the most important question is not where
are we going but how are we going to get
to whoever that is well it starts with
knowing and maybe we are the only
creatures on earth with a capacity not
only to understand what we understand
but then to act in a way that can
protect the systems the basic functions
of the planet that have have taken so
long to put into place and are becoming
unraveled so quickly in that same
half-century that we have learned more
it seems that maybe we have lost more at
least when you think about the numbers
half the coral reefs since I was a child
wasn't that long ago geologically
speaking
but they're gone
or they're in a state of serious decline
in the Caribbean 80% of the reefs that
were there in the 1950s are simply gone
that's scary stuff when you really think
about how long it took to get them to
where they were and how rapidly they're
coming apart about 90% of many of the
big fish and a lot of the little ones to
have been extracted from the ocean by us
we are new predators on these ancient
systems that have nothing in their life
history that is accounted for the steady
relentless predation that we impose
across the board the big ones the
medium-sized ones the little ones
whether they taste good or taste
horrible but can be used for something
like oil that we squeeze out of them or
grind them up to feed the cattle and
pigs and chickens that don't ask
questions too much about where their
food came from bottom of the ocean they
don't know it Wilson one of my favorite
humans the ant man from Harvard but a
lot more sort of a poet scientist he
acknowledges that over 10,000 years from
the beginnings of serious human
civilization coming together in North
America the pattern is clear we consumed
the large the slow and the tasty
creatures exterminating a number of
those that now exist only as fossils
some ancient memory perhaps we have deep
inside of us we're doing it much more
quickly in the ocean the large think
whales think tunas think that wonderful
creature eliminated within just a couple
of decades of its discovery a kind of
manatee that lives in lived now only in
memory
in in the Arctic Steller's sea cow gone
the Great Auk gone in the Gulf of Mexico
the Caribbean Sea once had monk seals
lounging on Miami Beach coming as far
north as Galveston Texas
as recently as 1952 ha
well I was a child but I didn't even
know of their existence and now they're
gone so we're still losing some of the
large and the slow huh they're the first
to go but we even take the fast like the
tuna and and other creatures some of the
fastest in the sea and even the taste
isn't an option necessary to qualify for
heavy levels of extraction think krill
in Antarctica where many are taken
thousands of tongues yanking the
cornerstone out of that tightly wound
system and what do we do we squeeze the
oil out of the krill or we grind them up
as pet food or animal food the animals
that we in turn eat or menhaden little
oily fish don't taste very good to us
but boy are they ever consumed by a lot
of other creatures in the sea so here we
are I think that journey that Tierney
took us on gave us certainly gave for me
a reminder of the whole the planet it
gives us life the most of it blue water
is the key no blue no water no life no
green no blue no green no water in their
life it's only about now that we're able
to see ourselves through that amazing
image from space the kids now grow up
with
but Stuart brand thank you for rocking
the boot and making sure that that image
was made public so that every little
school kid does grow up with it now and
assumes what I didn't know as a child
because that image didn't exist
at that time that when you turn the
world around there is a big blue face
the Pacific Ocean I can do it on a globe
I certainly had a classroom globe to
enjoy as a kid but it it isn't the same
not the same as having human eyes up
there looking back and holding that
little jewel that little speck in the
midst of a lot of very unfriendly
options out there just try setting up
housekeeping on Mars I think we will I
think it's cool I think we should I'd
like to go but I'd also like to come
back and here's the thing with all that
attention let's go set up housekeeping
on the moon Mars or the universe beyond
some would like to terraform Mars it's a
great idea I think but we don't have
four and a half billion years to make
Mars earth-like just think about what
we're doing to earth making it more Mars
like Mars are forming earth more co2 in
the atmosphere the atmosphere of Mars is
mostly co2 who are heading in that
direction not nearly the amount of co2
in the atmosphere here that Mars has in
fact the amount of co2 in the atmosphere
is tiny but it's just right just enough
to power photosynthesis to generate
oxygen fix food and make the planet
function but too much co2 is does not
favor us now there may be other
organisms that will say whoo-hoo let's
go let's get rid of all these other
pesky creatures because with more co2
perhaps our time has come
we've been lurking in the sidelines for
a billion years and now we can prosper
again our deep descendants may prosper
again earth will one way or the other go
on what now after a long time we are
looking at is a future the next ten
years are likely to be the most
important in the next 10,000 years
owing to what we do or don't do and
tyranny gave us a pretty good view of
why that's so what's happening what
we're doing to alter the nature of
nature and what the consequences are and
even what can we do about it well one of
the things I want to do about it is take
you on a dive to a couple of places in
the ocean that may underscore what we've
just been hearing and that is where
tyranny took us the Gulf Stream to the
Sargasso Sea off of Bermuda as a kid I
read books by William Beebe and I wanted
to do what that explorer did before I
was born with a fellow ocean lover and
engineer Otis Barton they cooked up an
idea they became a reality a bathysphere
a submarine that these two guys squirmed
their way into and got lowered like a
fish on a line over the side a half a
mile beneath the surface of the ocean
amazing they were the first humans to
make a roundtrip
a half a mile beneath the ocean and what
did they see it's like when the King
Tut's tomb was open what did you see
wonderful things that's what they saw
wonderful things they were diving into
the history of life on earth seeing what
we now recognize as possibly the most
common form of communication on earth
not the internet bioluminescence on the
order of 90% of the creatures in the
deep sea have some form of
bioluminescence and they speak with it
they flash they sparkle they glow they
lure in food they signaled to one
another think of this average depth of
the ocean is two-and-a-half miles four
thousand meters plus or minus a bit
maximum depth seven miles eleven
thousand meters go down a thousand feet
light is mostly gone a little bit is
there but not much even in the clearest
water off Bermuda in the Sargasso Sea
where these images were taken most of
life on earth lives in the dark not just
Sacramento Washington whatever
it's dark all of the time it's dark all
of the time in most of the ocean and
life has figured out the ways and means
of communicating of getting by using
bioluminescence or ignoring light
altogether but light in the Sargasso Sea
has throughout the illuminated part of
the ocean where photosynthesis occurs to
almost a thousand feet down
that's powers photosynthesis drives the
great ocean food webs generates most of
the oxygen in the atmosphere and a lot
of it not by the golden rainforest the
big creatures are the kelp forests it's
a little guys that do the heavy lifting
prochlorococcus you may not have heard
that before
tyranny uttered the word prochlorococcus
but get with it you know about petunias
and poinsettias and you know about all
the other kinds of plants we eat but
prochlorococcus enables you to breathe I
mean about 20% of the oxygen in the
atmosphere is generated by that one kind
of blue-green bacterium alone imagine we
didn't even know it existed until 1985
so much more to be learned with only 5%
of the ocean seen let alone really
explored and I'm so glad that Turney
included this sweep of technology that
has enabled us in very recent times
mostly the last 25 years gaining access
to the ocean is never before but the
first beginnings of it really began back
there well I guess the very first
beginnings when people began thinking
about access to the sea with boats on
the surface Alexander the Great is said
to have developed a kind of Bell enabled
whether he actually tried it out or he
had one of his
expendables try it but to actually in a
glass Bell over the person's head to
walk around and see what was under the
surface that was in 4bc I'm told but
whatever the evolution of what we now
enjoy has had a long beginning to reach
where we are now and we are just
beginning to seriously access the ocean
most of it
think of the deep sea where it's dark
all the time where carl's exist the
oldest known living animal that we know
so far is a carl in the deep sea known
as gold Carl seven thousand years in the
making some think perhaps as much as
nine thousand years what was the world
like five thousand years ago where were
human beings when some of these deep
Karl's first began to grow so here we
are with the capacity to destroy them or
to continue together one of the places
that our technologies have taken us
where humans have not been able to go
before until 2007 was the real North
Pole not where Admiral Peary went at the
top of the ocean in 1909 but the bottom
several miles beneath the ice so I want
to take you there
I wish I could take you there I wish I
could take myself there but in fact the
Russians did it were there two
submarines me r1 and Mir two Mir means
peace I hope they practice peace in the
ocean especially in the Arctic because
the Russians really have more control
more say than any other nation and
they're being pretty pushy about
exerting their influence and in fact
during a dive historic dive in 2007
you'll see a glimpse of it where the
mirror subs made that great descent and
returned they planted a titanium flag in
the heart of the Arctic at the North
Pole with a lot of our fellow mammals
have made the Arctic their home there
our future is very much at risk because
of the changes that are now taking place
it isn't just because of the climate
change not just because of ocean
acidification that threatens the great
ocean food webs it's also you know
humans continue with a fine art of
predation just like our ancestors years
ago as hunter-gatherers we've pretty
much narrowed that down to a sport on
the land there are a few places where
people rely largely on bush meat for
their sustenance but in the ocean the
ocean we are consuming bush meat it's
all wildlife we don't think of it that
way we were hunter-gatherers there like
green glow that you saw on the underside
of the ice rich forests that are really
tiny as individuals but those lush
forests power the energy cycles of food
for the little fish that the birds
it's dive happy I wish I could dive as
deep as some of these birds do holding
my breath humans have the capacity to
perhaps go down and some humans have
gone more than a hundred meters more
than you know some are hoping to get
down to 500 feet on a single breath of
air power assisted with weights and you
know getting some assistance coming back
to the surface but nonetheless surviving
with long breath hold dives well here
you don't have to hold your breath if
you're in a submarine it's one
atmosphere you can go as deep as the MIR
subs they go to 6000 meters well at the
top of the world the maximum depth is
about 5,000 meters plus event nuclear
submarines have powered their way under
the Arctic ice measuring the thickness
of the ice which they now have perceived
since the 1950s is noticeably thinning
from beneath so top of the world plant
the flag there they are a century ago
and here Russia is planting the flag
very recently 2007 and now although the
top of the world is another global
Commons even beyond the extent that
Russia is trying to claim there is a
place at the top of the world that is
high seas and whether you're talking
about the five nations that border the
Arctic or the eight nations that are
involved with an Arctic Council the fact
of the matter is that every person
whatever their nationality wherever
they've come from have a vested interest
in what happens to the Arctic our voices
have special resonance in the high seas
part of the Arctic but we all should be
weighing in with concern about what's
happening to what amounts to the planets
air conditioning system the Arctic and
of course Antarctica as well big changes
more changes that we are witnessing
than any that have been witnessed in the
history of humankind now some of this is
obviously natural I mean there are
cycles that come and go through time but
we have pushed the fast-forward button
changing the way the world works without
knowing what the outcome is so let's go
to another place let's go to a place
that you will perhaps recognize because
it's right here it's your backyard this
part any of you can see just walk down
to Monterey Bay drive down moderate walk
if you like there's the Pacific Ocean as
seen from the land and they're a part of
the Pacific Ocean that until recent
times humans were simply unaware of its
existence oh the creatures who live
there knew all about the Monterey Canyon
but when I was the chief scientist of
NOAA the head of NOAA John canals had a
great image on his wall that was
published in 1857 and it was of the
Monterey Bay and it showed soundings
going out into the bay and then they you
know sounding soundings sounding along
the shore and then it just sort of
stopped they didn't know if they didn't
have lines deep enough to know what was
out there and then he had next to it one
of the modern toda NOAA's charts that
showed in immense detail the
configuration of that Grand Canyon of
the sea curiously though now it's one of
the best map parts of the planet but
only about 5% of the ocean has been
mapped with the same kind of detail that
we have for Monterey Bay for the moon
for Mars for Jupiter you know now I
worked on an atlas of the ocean oh this
is for you Tony
ha this is tourney's gotta be your
favorite fish I don't mean to eat maybe
that too but I don't think so this big
bony fish ocean sunfish wonderful I you
know when you look into that eye
somebody's home and everyone is
different from every other one I didn't
really appreciate that until I'd spent
lots of time underwater looking at fish
looking at crabs looking at shrimp
looking at life in the sea up close and
personal we know every otter is unique
like every dog every cat those that are
brought back to health after they've
been abandoned or damaged at the
Monterey Bay Aquarium they they nurse
them back to health and restore them to
every one has its own personality they
all look different I it's just one of
those things that shockingly came into
focus for me that all creatures maybe
every single prochlorococcus cell is
unique with its own little tiny DNA
fingerprint it's a miracle that great
capacity for diversity the other miracle
is how connected we all are that our DNA
and prochlorococcus in' and ocean
sunfish and giant kelp sand whatever it
is there's a lot we have in common with
all other living things I think it's
it's the miracle of life and knowing it
is maybe another miracle what is it
about us it gives us the power of asking
questions and then finding answers and
then as never before with those 7
billion minds that tyranny mentioned
capacity maybe to figure it out maybe
just in time before we go too far in
altering the nature of nature of doing
what it takes to hold the planet steady
that's cause for hope national parks we
dreamed up that idea in this country
some say the best idea America ever had
early in the 20th century now we're
edging into the 21st with another good
idea of brewing and that is to have
protected areas in the sea on the land
it wasn't really aimed at protecting the
planet so that we could have a
prosperous future it was more because
places were beautiful and they were
being wrecked and Teddy Roosevelt was
cross and he used the power of the
presidency to sign into the law using
the antiquities Act monuments you think
of a monument is a piece of granite or
something well he saw a monuments in a
different way
the living monuments and national parks
many of them started out as monuments
and morphed into this network of
protected areas on the land and around
the world about 14 creeping up to 15
percent of the land has some form of
protection as a park or reserve whatever
in countries around the world all of
that in little more than a century
Yellowstone was established in 1872 the
wasn't a National Park System that was
was a National Park and that was the
year that the first oceanographic
expedition launched from the shores of
England to explore the ocean of the
world much as you've explored it thanks
to tyrannies great expedition around the
world but they were at the surface they
did not have even mask and fins they
lowered devices like the fishermen they
were scientific fishing dragging the
ocean floor bringing things up dumping
them on the deck trying to figure out
what was there if you could bring to
this stage somebody from the Challenger
expedition and ask them just sit in the
audience and watch what who you just
seen what do you suppose would surprise
them the most been to the moon
you have images of Mars up in space and
of course they be dazzled by that and if
anybody had a cell phone go off why they
probably wonder what's that the idea
that you could talk with this little
device with people all over the world
and hit a few buttons you can download
the Library of Congress any element of
it that you wish I mean the technologies
would would surely blow them away I
think they might be as amazed by what we
have not done knowing what we know and
seeing how marvelous our technologies
are where they've enabled us to to be
what do you mean they might say only
three people have been to the deepest
part of the ocean it's only seven miles
seven miles is nothing and it took you
until 1960 to get there the first time
and then 2012 James Cameron a filmmaker
an engineer a genius but all things
considered what might surprise them the
most is that we haven't done more to
safeguard our future I'm surprised
knowing what I now know that it's so
hard to get people to understand the
value of what nature delivers to us free
like breath like water like life and I
love Tommy rebenga sell the President of
Palau who has finally taken action
because he gets it partly economically
eighty five million for tourism five
million to extract the wildlife from the
sea fishing hmm I wonder what I should
do I think I should protect the 85
million but he's also protecting his
reefs he's protecting his life it's not
just about money
one thing that money cannot buy is a
planet that works in our favor we all
have to get behind the concept of
protecting nature land air the fabric of
life certainly the ocean hope spots
represent a beginning there like
national parks if you will but for other
reasons to underscore to underpin the
planet that works in our favor time for
us to return the favor thank you
you need it that is what's that don't
make it come I've got to do with some
questions from the audience and you guys
may have some questions of each other
based on how recently have you guys
talked to each other oh just I don't
know last month two month last month
probably you're okay yeah no output
there we go way back way back yeah
before she got her PhD Duke University
ha ha Silvius alma mater and around my
my recommendations for graduate school
we bonded it was epoxy over the deep
flight making the deep flight
submersible many years ago with all
sorts of epoxy we're glued together
together a question comes up you talked
a lot Sylvia about the the that were and
we stopped living on wildlife from the
land but we're still living on wildlife
from the sea so Tom no comment a heavily
subsidized so farm fish is coming on
fast to something like third or half of
the fish that people eat now especially
in Asia is farm and so this question is
is good news bad news or mixed or what
it's may be so again I think there's
cause for for hope if if animal protein
is a desirable goal and for many that's
what I'm a 3/5 yeah but although omega-3
fatty acids are not made by the fish
they're actually from the algae there's
a fish consumed so it's not you don't
need to eat the fish to get those
omega-3 fatty acids we can eat the algae
of course and there are several
companies that are actually growing the
energy smart companies mark tech mm-hmm
and instead of squeezing a little
menhaden and getting the oil out of them
were squeezing the krill to get the oil
out of them
I don't know it's just marketing it's
just marketing and they do walk as much
what's it the algae don't squawk is and
they grow fast too and it takes a long
time those krill can be ten or twelve
years old it takes three years at least
for them to mature
I mean hens grow faster than that little
Creole T absolutely yeah and I mean
think about the fish that we we capture
I mean some of them are really old like
the orange roughy that was on no one's
menu until we started going down
thousands of people over the surface
knocking down these ancient Karl's to
get to where the fish aren't they can be
at least a hundred years old and some
are thought to be as much as 200 it
takes 30 years for them to mature how
many 30 year old cows have you eaten
lately really tough old water Kevin
Kelly this one one more thing culture
because it's a recurrent and an
important question much of aquaculture
is powered by wild fish that are fed to
the cultivated fish thinks salmon now
you might hear a salmon farmers say oh
it only takes five or six times the
amount of feed to get a pound of salmon
five to one or six to one or maybe only
four to one but it's not that's not real
accounting because it took a lot of
plants that the other the far end of the
food chain to make the little guys that
made the bigger guys to make the bigger
guys to get to the little fish that they
feed to the salmon so if you want real
accounting you have to start with
sunlight and plants and that's where
prochlorococcus does the heavy lifting
to power the tiny little copepods about
as big as a comma on a printed page and
they're gazillions of them that feed the
tiny fish and the larvae of everybody
else out there it's a very complicated
system but it the simple part is if you
want an honest accounting of what
what it takes to make a tuna fish
sandwich for example you have to start
at the beginning sunlight plants and you
have to think how old is the tuna that
went into your sandwich or your sushi or
sashimi because it takes bluefin tuna
that people love to eat according to
Barbara block Stanford 10 to 14 years
for them to mature they may live to be
30 years and every step of the way you
know they are eating eating eating every
year think about a 10 year old kid
how many Big Macs and french fries and
whatever else it is that goes into
making a 10 year old kid or one of you
how many think of the groceries have
gone into to make all of condensed into
making you now so the younger the fish
or the animal the lower on the food
chain
plants sunlight plants chicken it's
about 2 pounds of plants to make one
pound of chicken but for tuna a 10 year
old tuna you've got to think in terms of
thousands of pounds of plants so
aquaculture any any carnivores forget it
you know the best choices are probably
catfish tilapia carp grazers that grow
fast you know a year or so but if you
really want to be smart eat the plants
photosynthesize figure out how to do
that photosynthetic skin would solve so
many problems but there are some really
interesting aquaculture solutions that
are making balanced ecosystems so
instead of monocultures which we know
have all sorts of problems we have
polycultures where you're being able to
there's one called integrated
multi-trophic aquaculture that's a good
name just kind of rolls off the toms be
an acronym and but being able to harvest
from multiple trophic levels so you have
a balanced ecosystem that supports
itself so that's one that's looking
promising there's also a more innovative
food supplies like the latest one I
heard of is black soldier fly larvae
which lives on cow and pig
and makes huge amounts of protein
arthropods are really insects are really
good at this kind of thing and being
able to harvest that's figured that out
a long time yes exactly and so
harvesting from a food source that's a
very fast turnover and can be grown on
on waste products is looking really
promising so I think we we have to
figure out aquaculture if we're going to
provide enough protein we have to eat
more plants and Kathy so I've asked can
you give us an update on the status of
the sea star wasting syndrome on our
coast
the stars are in trouble what's going on
yeah I hear that there are some recovery
not all places are as hard-hit but it's
still it's still not solved as far as I
know it's still a mystery as to what's
what's going on so it what happens is
that these sea stars are just starting
to disintegrate and and I'm not sure if
they have calcium carbonate shells you
know embedded in the skin and they're
very sensitive to changes in the pH of
their environment that may be part of
part of what's happening or it may be
something totally unrelated some yeah
it's a mystery that but part some areas
are recovering and other parts are still
seeing it so it's still a big area of
research another item in the news is
supposedly there's a great big del Nino
on taking shape in the East Pacific we
don't know if it's going to be a big one
that's still that's still unknown
because it well it's looking similar to
what we saw in 97 based on these these
images and it's good it's kind of
interesting recalls remind us what
happened in 97 97 was a was a was a big
El Nino you had
and there was what flooding and droughts
and flooding and when you have warm
water a lot of you know you just have a
shifting of the just like what we see
when we were raising the temperature of
the ocean that you have a huge shifting
and who's who's eating whom populations
falling out I mean I think um 82 was
another huge one that swept through
Galapagos and Galapagos has never never
recovered from that well and you have
kelp needs a certain temperature to
prosper so when you don't have to kill
for its cup for still go down and then
everything you know the hundreds and
hundreds of species that rely in the
company worse I think they're really
interesting the good news is that humans
have the capacity for the first time to
even understand something about how El
Nino is formed and why when NOAA the
agency National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Agency was first glued together from
several departments of the government
the primary goal was to try to get the
atmospheric guys together with the ocean
community so that they were kind of
forced to get their act together the
ocean after all drives climate and
weather but you don't even now read a
lot about when you hear about climate
change it's about the atmosphere and
what we're putting into the atmosphere
but you should listen up it's the ocean
that drives all of it it really shapes
the temperature and that those great
currents moving the air above it
creating much of what we think of as the
wind and holding the planet steady as
the great thermal regulator the whole
concept of understanding El Nino really
got it underway in the 1970s it's been
known off the coast of Peru where it's a
really clear phenomenon when it happens
when that
warm water comes across the Pacific and
washes the shores of Peru where it's
usually cold temperate water with kelp
forests like we have here and everything
changes for a while and bacteria cause
the sulfur bacteria blacken the painted
surfaces they call it the black painter
comes around Christmastime when it
happens so they think of El Nino as the
child the Christ child Christmas
question Sylvia the microbes which
you've been focusing on in the ocean
which are responsible for atmosphere and
other things we care about and bottom of
the food chain all of this is microbial
life much affected do you think by
climate change or is it shrug off things
like that which microbes are you talking
you know the crank out a lot of oxygen
we probably care about we don't know I I
think we should what has been noticed
though that since 1950 there is a
decline of photosynthetic fighter what
the phytoplankton mmm-hmm I was buy some
and maybe he heap in a lot on a few
studies but by some analysis it's as
much as forty percent that's a lot I
can't imagine that it's really that much
globally but even if it's five percent
you lose five percent of your lungs
notice there's enough stability in what
already exists that it's taken so long
to get it to the place that it is it it
it may take a long while before the
effects of losing a big chunk of you and
think of all the forests that have been
cut think of the word we're down in
North America to about five percent of
the old-growth forests they are the most
productive of all in terms of of
generating oxygen now a new forest grows
fast and you get a lot of turnover but
think of the biome
of a redwood tree with all those little
needles doing their thing and all the
mosses and all the ferns and all the
rest of it it's not just you know like a
lawn where you get photosynthesis acting
very quickly but there's no substitute
for what we've destroyed already what
makes it cold why is it more acidic and
it's old I would have thought that this
is presumably not the acidification that
were causing because it's been sinking
it's been sinking carbon as well and
then and then once you're so what makes
it old is not reaching the surface and
so and also so as it's traveling it's
also taking in a lot of the carbon
dioxide from the respiratory processes
of all the life that is in the ocean as
well so that adds to it in addition to
the carbon from and so we have we have
more mixing in the surface waters but
when you're very pleasing carbon dioxide
the ocean actually releases a ton of
carbon dioxide it it sinks a lot of
carbon dioxide but it releases a lot of
carbon dioxide as well but when it's
very low all that stays in and all the
respiratory excellent of the king
process and all the life goes down there
it doesn't get mixed it stays down there
and not having access to the surface
it's also full of nutrients right that's
why these upwellings are these
incredibly fertile biodiverse back up on
it well you get first the micro mmm
[Music]
plants that make the megafauna possible
it's the food chain you get the
nutrients I mean you wouldn't get blue
whales in Monterey Bay if you didn't
have a heck of a lot of phytoplankton
out there to start with mm-hmm
that makes the krill possible that makes
the whales possible now here's the other
thing you know I attend a number of food
security conferences because
I'm really curious at the thought that
we have to kill fish for secure food
security well we don't but the the idea
that forming is very tightly connected
to fertilizer you know you're very
conscious of where the nutrients come
from that cause the corn and other
things to to prosper in the ocean
there's no waste you know the
phytoplankton is eaten by little
copepods that poop fertilizer back into
the system
little fish eat the copepods and they
poop and it goes back into the system
the whales eat the little fish that eat
the cocoa pods that you know so on and
so on when they give back I just
realized I have no idea what the whale
poop is like we've all hear about pink
well it's suggested whatever yeah or
whatever it is Stewart the the
phytoplankton just says a delicious
Mahna Mahna from heaven mega for our
famous for moving nutrients around yeah
that's right and but they're always
giving back and see that it's part of
what the chemistry of the ocean and
people want to go swimming in it
coming down to the end here ask each of
you Kevin Kelley's question what are the
really outstanding questions and
mysteries that we still have and both of
you focused on how much knowledge is
then in the last hundred years and how
much is only 5% map but we've been a lot
of places and you you know you showed us
the current we didn't know where the
current was honored years ago we just
knew there's weirdness so a lot is known
but what is unknown and is important to
find out you first journey well I think
our biggest questions are how are we
going to define our relationship with
the ocean and how are we going to be
able to extract what we need from it
without destroying it and and we've you
know in some ways we do know a lot about
the ocean but in a lot of ways it's
still a total mystery we cannot predict
a lot of what happens in the ocean some
things that surprised us recently we
thought we had figured out well I mean
still the uncertainty of El Nino we're
getting there but we still don't know if
it's going to be a big one until we're
about maybe three to four months into it
and then we'll be like it's gonna be a
big one I mean we can certifiably say
it's going to be a big one cuz we're in
it and I mean that's the way ocean
science is I mean we have we just found
this incredible decadal process in the
ocean called the Pacific decadal
oscillation whereas El Nino is more like
a 17-month phenomenon the the Pacific
decadal oscillation is more on the order
of 20 to 30 years and we get you know
two to three degree temperature changes
on our coasts when we're in a certain
phase of the Pacific decadal oscillation
and then when you have an El Nino on top
of that oh man we're really hammering
the ocean when we and so and we didn't
know that that the Pacific had this huge
process in it we're just discovering
that with proxies with fish scales and
you know we we're finding that out so
our forecasts ability is still lacking
you know so but we're we're trying to
put it all together that's why cabled
observatories that give us this 24/7
presence in the ocean where we can
weather the storms you know that's when
a lot of the big actions happening in
the ocean when you have a huge storm
massive massive stirring up lots of
carbon sinking lots of nutrients and
that's when the scientists are like get
my equipment out of there it's gonna get
destroyed that's when all the equipment
has to be there because those are the
big episodic events that are defining
the character of the ocean so brave
robots in the storm yes yes that don't
get seasick and won't see you I know
no mattias robots allowed so that's I
think that's my biggest my biggest
question is are we going to are we going
to recognize the importance of the ocean
fast enough to put our money where our
mouth is and supply the resources
financially and emotionally and
cognitively to to study the ocean do
science do preservation it sounds like
with all that you've said and maybe just
add a few touches that we I think
President Obama made the comment that
our highest priority must be to keep the
world safe for our children so he was
thinking guns and things but that
comment our highest priority must be to
keep the world safe for those coming
along that's what our predecessors in a
way did for us our parents took care of
us as kids and wished us well provided
for us not so we could just be the end
of the world but a new beginning for
whatever might follow and here we are
the beginning of this new century armed
with unprecedented knowledge an
unprecedented opportunity the important
oh we don't know why the ocean matters
we don't know that I mean I think I have
a glimpse it keeps us alive the ocean is
our life-support system it just is and
the most important thing that we take
out of the ocean is our existence it's
not oil gas fish crabs oysters or
anything else or even the fun that we
enjoy it's we need to protect the ocean
as if our lives depend on it because
they do and knowing that making the
connections you know we're so fascinated
with going high in the sky and we should
be I love it and it's paid off enormous
ly we have all these great benefits
owing to satellites and transportation
all over the place and the knowledge
that we now have is largely because we
burn through millions of years of fossil
energy to get us to where we are and
maybe the greatest gift of that is to
see that we've got to change our ways
else we're cooked
literally but we've collected the ocean
we've taken it for granted we have
imagined the ocean was too big to fail
our policies we have a billion dollar
agency in our government the National
Marine Fisheries Service that's
dedicated to catching killing marketing
fish and helping fishermen do it with
subsidized loans and things you know
it's when are we going to lift above
that attitude about the ocean not as a
place from which we extract oh it's okay
to fish it's okay to take some things
but as long as you are not disrupting
the basic engine that keeps us alive and
that's what is lacking it's that
connection between because partly
because we don't we can't supply
straight answers to some of the straight
questions people ask because we've only
done this much but the precautionary
principle would say well we we know what
we know now having explored maybe 5%
doesn't it seem obvious that it's so
important why aren't we going flat out
as we did in the 60s to go skyward with
all the benefits that have come about
and and while robots are great and to
swim around there's no substitute for
having human beings in the ocean ice
thousands of hours under water I
wouldn't think the way I think had I not
literally been there and and or feel
driven to share the view with all of you
if I hadn't been there the Jim Cameron
who made that great descent to the
deepest part of the ocean and came back
fortunately he said little kids don't
want to grow up to be robots they want
to be explorers they want to know they
want to go they want to be there I want
to be there I want you to go there I
want you to see for yourself and even if
you get seasick
or if you have to go into I mean you got
pilots flying into the eye of a
hurricane to see what's there
well if they can do that human beings
and tiny little piece of machinery up in
the sky why can't we take the risk and
forget about suing people for heaven's
sakes and go into the ocean I mean we've
got to be the greatest risk is in not
taking risks and getting out there and
really understanding the ocean works
they're not mutually exclusive by any
measure I mean you've got your man your
will man sense but not many and not many
like and your and your your are Ovie's
your a you've ease you're really barrel
your open are Ovie's you know home and
toolbox you need you need all of them
they're by no means by no means mutually
exclusive and I mean it's seriously 99
percent of our living space and
seen less than 5% with her own eyes we
got a lot out there we got a lot of
exploring don't know how this air force
iesson for pleasure or would you like to
dive for science for pleasure like like
to dive dive for science or for pleasure
tomorrow what do you want to go anywhere
so 50 years ago I almost anywhere 50
years ago I'd love to see the way look
know that were 50 years from now to see
what it helps you you'd like to go
really deep loved I'm so jealous of
Cameron for I pestered him and I pointed
out that I fit in that little submarine
better than he does for a while maybe
someday but and no no woman has been to
the bottom of the ocean it's there to be
done where do you think go to the
deepest part of the ocean because if you
can go there you can go anywhere in the
ocean and right across the bay and deep
ocean exploration and research their
their plans with a glass submarine glass
is a wonderful material very strong
under pressure and we ought to be
exploring the but it might take 50
million dollars to build a 3-person so
made of glass most of that would be
testing the actual building of it would
maybe be 5 million how many yachts are
there that cost a hundred million
dollars right and we could go to where
no yacht has ever been the round trip
must have been one way
perhaps I'm reading 20,000 leagues under
the seas right now that is the great
long fantasy that humans have had and I
think this is OK Silicon Valley let's do
it we should glass submarine for people
to see what you've seen and have not
just just a handful of lucky scientists
go or lucky film directors explorers who
make films so they can explore with
submarines they build themselves but
nothing wrong with that I love that
entrepreneurial spirit they just should
have made one for you yeah why not -
well you know it shouldn't be just a
privileged place for a handful of eyes
and minds to go we need poets there we
need to get the corporate leaders there
we need the heads of state to see what
they're doing to the ocean we need kids
to go to tell people to take care of
their planet I mean really we need
access to the sea journey or do you want
to dive the place I would love to dive
most is the first place where my son and
daughter are on scuba gear with me and
we can stay deep for a long time and
really get to know some fish in their
own area and I don't know where that's
going to be maybe Indonesia but at this
rate my own daughter is quite the fish
her brother's not far behind they're
still not old enough to get certified
but when they are that is going to be
the place that is going to be one of the
most special places ever I like it get
kids in the water get politicians in the
water yes change the world thank you
guys
thank you
[Music]
you